supongamos que aquí tenemos esta función
de apariencia extraña es una función
arbitraria vamos a llamarla f x deja le
escribo por aquí
efe de x lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es un experimento para intentar
aproximar esta función usando un
polinomio con ciertos coeficientes vamos
a empezar con una constante y poco a
poco le sumaremos más y más términos
para aumentar el grado y mejorar nuestra
aproximación a esto se le llama una
serie de potencias pero bueno ya
hablaremos más acerca de eso después por
el momento trataremos de aproximar esta
función alrededor de x es igual a 0 es
decir alrededor de este punto entonces
comencemos con lo más fácil cuales son
los polinomios más sencillos que
conocemos pues los de grado cero
entonces comencemos con un polinomio pd
x que es constante es igual a cierta k
entonces lo que vamos a tener en la
gráfica es una línea horizontal si
quisiéramos que está acá nos ayudará a
aproximar a efe alrededor de cero pues
nos conviene que pase por este punto es
decir vamos a tomar acá igual a efe de
cero
entonces en la gráfica nos quedaría una
línea horizontal más o menos así ahorita
boro esta línea porque no quiero que se
me encima mucho mi dibujo pero bueno
para agarrar un poco de la intuición lo
que hace esta línea es aproximar a efe
pero pues mal sea la verdad lo aproxima
mal pero como sólo tenemos una constante
deshacer como sólo tenemos una constante
pues es una forma de empezar verdad
pedirle que pase por efe de cero como le
podemos hacer para aproximar un poco
mejor que tal que pedimos que no sólo p
de x sea igual a efe de 0 hay porque no
quería esto vale entonces qué tal que es
decir hasta ahorita lo que logramos
déjame escribirlo para ir con calma a
ver ya tenemos que perder 0 es igual a
efe de 0 porque pues p es constante y es
igual a efe de 0 entonces en cualquier
valor vale efe de cero eso nos da una
aproximación muy mala pero qué tal que
intentamos hacer algo para que la
derivada del polinomio es decir prima
evaluada en cero también sea igual a la
derivada d
efe es decir f prima evaluada en 0 va
esto de aquí son un poco más interesante
cómo le hacemos para lograr esto pues
fíjate voy a proponer pd x ahorita
estamos trabajando muy en general ya
después vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
más concretos para fijar las ideas pero
vamos a pedir la p de x que sea igual a
este término constante es decir f de 0 y
además de esto vamos a sumar la derivada
de f la derivada de la función o sea la
pendiente f prima en cero y esto
multiplicado por equis va entonces aquí
hay un polinomio al cual le agregué un
término de primer grado ahora tenemos un
polinomio lineal pues y lo que voy a
confirmar es que tienen la misma
derivada que f bueno además nos gustaría
que no se perdiera lo de antes es decir
nos gustaría ver que puede ser o sea
igual a efe de 0 y pues sí porque este
otro término es f prima de 0 x 0 que lo
podemos cancelar esto porque cualquier
cosa por cero de acero y cualquier cosa
más cero es la cualquiera
la palomita va entonces en x es igual a
0 p
efe coinciden ahora vamos a confirmar
que su primer derivada también coincide
vamos a pasarnos para acá para escribir
la derivada de p
y entonces p prima es igual a esto de
aquí es constante entonces nos queda 0
más la derivada de esta expresión es
simplemente una constante por equis y
una constante por equis su deriva de
simplemente la constante f prima de 0
listo entonces esto es justo lo que
queremos nuestro nuevo polinomio este
que acabamos de definir por acá cumple
dos cosas 1 es igual a la función efe en
x es igual a 0 y además su derivada
también es igual a la derivada de la
función en x es igual a 0 como se vería
esto pues como es un polinomio lineal va
a ser una línea lo de que p de 0 es
igual a efe de 0 va a ser que pase por
este punto pero además van a tener la
misma tangente bueno más bien su
tangente va a tener la misma pendiente
déjame hacer un dibujo
se vería más o menos algo así
y esto de aquí pues ya es una
aproximación un poco mejor cita verdad
si tuviéramos que usar una línea ésta es
al parecer la mejor que podemos tomar
esto está bueno no sabemos muy bien cómo
sff podría hacer algunas cosas muy locas
pero con una expresión tan simple como
una expresión lineal pudimos aproximar
la pues razonablemente bien
seguramente vamos a poder hacer un mejor
trabajo si le aumentamos un término
cuadrática es decir si ahora le ponemos
por aquí algo que tenga que ver con x
cuadrada lo que queremos lograr es tres
cosas verdad número uno queremos lograr
que en x es igual a cero las funciones
sean iguales también queremos lograr que
en x es igual a cero las derivadas
coincidan y ahora con nuestro tercer
término queremos lograr que las segundas
derivadas sean iguales va como le
podemos hacer para lograr hacer esto
déjame proponer otro polinomio más a ver
vamos a intentar
voy a poner un nuevo pe y ese nuevo p va
a ser px es igual a y los primeros dos
términos van a ser los mismos
efe de cero y luego vamos a sumar el
mismo término lineal
efe prima de cero y esto multiplicado
por x y el tercer término va a ser f
doble prima es decir la segunda derivada
de f evaluada en cero y ahora vamos a
multiplicar por algo un poco más extraño
vamos a multiplicar por x al cuadrado
pero dividido entre dos a lo mejor este
dividir entre dos te saque un poco de
onda porque pues antes no habíamos
dividido entre nada pero bueno ya
después te vas a dar cuenta a qué se
debe esto cuando tomemos la segunda
derivada el exponente va a bajar
entonces va a cancelar con el 2 entonces
pues más o menos por ahí va a aparecer
un 1 que va a compensar todas las cosas
entonces pues más o menos es entre 2
tiene que ver con que se compensa con
una derivada que vamos a hacer por ahí
vamos a hacer las cuentas para confirmar
que esto es cierto entonces p de 0 es
igual a efe de 0 más y ahora estos
términos tienen ceros multiplicando
tenemos aquí un cero aquí también
tenemos otro 0 + 0 entonces palomita
puede ser es igual f de 0 vamos con la
primera derivada vamos con p prima de x
y eso de ahí es igual a haber veamos
tenemos saber creo que aquí arriba más
bien era cero no es la primera derivada
en cero va entonces regresando aquí
abajo tenemos la derivada de una
constante que es 0 +
y creo que acá arriba si estábamos bien
si este prima de x solo que como es una
función constante pues da lo mismo o sea
igual queda f prima de 0 vaya pero no
quiero confundirte regresemos a lo que
estábamos entonces la derivada de f 0 es
cero
aquí tenemos f prima de cero y luego hay
que sumar y fíjate esto es lo que te
decía la derivada de este término pues a
ver el exponente lo bajamos
multiplicamos dos por un medio se
cancela simplemente nos queda ese doble
prima de 0 x x esta verdad el exponente
lo multiplicamos y le bajamos en 1 ok
entonces ahora queremos ver cuánto es p
prima es decir la que acabamos de
encontrar evaluada en 0 pues este 0 es
un cero entonces nos queda f prima de
cero y hay que sumar esta expresión
evaluada en cero pero es un cero
entonces otra vez palomita ya logramos
hacer que las primeras derivadas
coincidan y ahora pasemos a la segunda
derivada déjame borrar la parte de
arriba entonces voy a agarrar mi
rectángulo negro y
por aquí y por acá y estas manchitas
también no quieren borrarse está
entonces pasemos a la segunda derivada
vamos a encontrar la segunda derivada de
la p que nos toca esta de aquí que estoy
marcando con rosa entonces la tercera
derivada o sea p triple prima de x aquí
puede haberle puesto un 3 para
simplificar un poco esto de aquí es
igual a la derivada de prima a no no no
perdón apenas vamos en la segunda
derivada en p doble prima de x ok eso de
ahí es igual a pues a la derivada de
prima de x pues vamos a ver cómo vamos
este primer término ya era cero aquí
tenemos una constante que al derivar las
devuelve 0 ya nada más nos falta derivar
este aquí tenemos una constante por x a
lo mejor esto de aquí no parece una
constante porque pues parece una función
pero no hay que caer en esa trampa una
vez que derivamos dos veces y evaluamos
en cero ya se convierte en un número
entonces simplemente tenemos una
constante por equis y su derivada es la
constante o sea ese doble prima
entonces esta función pe que propusimos
o bueno este polinomio p tiene el mismo
valor de f cuando x es igual a 0 tiene
la misma primera derivada en x es igual
a 0 y también tiene la misma segunda
derivada en x es igual a 0 va a ser un
poco más difícil pasar al dibujo pero
bueno voy a hacer mi mejor esfuerzo en
dibujarlo como esto de aquí es de grado
2 va a ser una parábola entonces la
parábola va a venir por acá va a tocar
en el punto que nos interesa con la
misma pendiente y luego va a bajar esto
de aquí en la mano estoy adivinando pero
espero que sea más o menos así en
realidad lo que vamos a obtener es una
mejor aproximación para ello por
supuesto podríamos seguir haciendo esto
y de hecho lo vamos a seguir haciendo es
decir ahorita ya logramos que la función
coincida que la derivada coincida y que
la segunda derivada coincida pero lo
mismo podríamos hacer con la tercera con
la cuarta y así como ya se nos acabó el
tiempo lo veremos hasta el próximo vídeo